Let's talk about one of the most
dangerous habits on our side. Something
so subtle we don't even realize we're
doing it. It's the casual constant use
of the term the left. Now, I get it. It
feels like convenient shortorthhand,
left versus right, liberals versus
conservatives, that old political
spectrum we've all been taught to
believe in. But here's the thing. That
spectrum is a complete lie. It's not
just false, it's a trap. It forces us to
frame every issue as if we're just
choosing between two flavors of opinion.
As if truth and falsehood, order and
chaos, good and evil, are just personal
preferences. And that's exactly how the
madness spreads. By calling it the left,
we make it sound like it's just a
different viewpoint, legitimate,
respectable, maybe even worth
considering. It's not. It's wrong. It's
insane. And in many cases, it's pure
evil. Let me give you an example. A man
says he's a woman. He demands access to
women's bathrooms, women's prisons,
women's sports. He insists that you
affirm his delusion or be punished. Is
this just the left? No. It's a big fat
lie. And when you call it leftist, you
give it structure. You give it standing.
You turn insanity into ideology. You let
it sit at the table as if it deserves to
be there. It doesn't. It belongs outside
with the rest of the trash. Here's the
real danger. Once you buy into the left
versus right dichotomy, you stop judging
things by whether they're true and start
judging them by where they land on the
line. Oh, I guess drag queens reading to
kids is just something on the left.
Wrong. It's not left. It's predatory.
Oh, I guess aborting babies is just
their position on reproductive rights.
Wrong. It's murder. The language
currently being employed flattens the
moral universe. It takes objective
eternal truths and makes them sound like
opinions. It turns perversion into
expression, blasphemy into progress, and
delusion into identity. This isn't just
semantics, it's warfare, linguistic
warfare. And the left, yes, that's what
they also call themselves, understands
it perfectly. They've spent decades
reprogramming language, redefining words
like man, woman, marriage, freedom,
justice, even reality itself. And now
the right is playing along. They say
gender affirming care, we say trans
surgery. They say choice, we say
abortion. They say minor attracted
persons. And we still call them
progressive. Why could it be because
we're afraid to call it what it is,
evil? Because we think calling it left
is safer, more polite. But that's not
just weak, it's collaboration. If we're
serious about defending truth, we have
to stop pretending this is about
politics. This is not left versus right.
This is truth versus falsehood. Sanity
versus delusion. Yes, light versus
darkness. And here's the thing. This
didn't used to be political at all. Even
atheists used to believe in facts. Even
liberals used to know what a woman was.
But now, now they've thrown out truth
entirely. It's not just there is no God.
It's there's no reality. And we're still
out here talking about the political
spectrum. Still pretending that people
who think they're the opposite gender
are just far-left. Still acting like
this is a policy disagreement. No, this
is a war. A spiritual war. People of
faith should know this more than anyone
else. God never gave a spectrum. He gave
commandments. He gave law. He gave truth
and warned what happens when it's
rejected. There is no middle ground
between truth and falsehood. There is no
compromise between male and female.
There is no neutral position when
children are being mutilated. When lies
are being codified, when evil is being
paraded through the streets like a
virtue. So stop calling it the left.
Stop giving this madness the dignity of
ideology. Stop giving it a place at the
table. It's not leftist to say men can
breastfeed. It's not leftist to say kids
can change sex. It's not leftist to
teach porn in schools. It's insanity.
It's perversion. It's war against
reality. And when you call it left, you
help it hide. Instead, call it what it
is. Call it evil. Call it confusion.
Call it rebellion, cowardice, or
madness. But don't call it just the
other side. Because the truth is not one
end of a spectrum. The truth is a rock,
unmoving, unchanging. And everything
else is either built on it or shattered
by it. So speak like it, fight like it,
and stop giving ground, especially with
your words. Because in the end, this
isn't about politics. It's about truth
and there is no left or right when it
comes to truth. There is only right or
wrong.